Hello everybody, my
name is Sherry Zachary.
I'm a former
NYIT student,
and I currently
practice radiology
with a subspecialty
in neuroradiology.
I'm here to talk
to you about the
clinical applications
of neuroimaging.
The way this talk
is gonna work
is that we're gonna
discuss different
modalities used in radiology
to image the brain.
Within each
modality, I'm going
to describe to
you the clinical
indications in
which way we may use
that modality to
image the brain.
I'm going to understand
the contraindications
to that form of
brain imaging.
And then I'll give you
some other clinical
notes on how to
integrate the imaging
with other clinical
tools to ultimately
manage neurologic disease.
Before we get into
the modalities used
to image the brain,
let's just talk
about some of the
clinical scenarios
that would then lead us
as clinicians to
order brain imaging.
Syncope, essentially
passing out,
often caused by a
low blood pressure.
Transient ischemic
attack, a mini-******,
a reversible
neurologic deficit,
usually lasting less
than 30 minutes.
******, which is an
irreversible neurologic
deficit, that is,
until treatment is
started. altered mental
status any change
from the patient's
baseline mental status
is considered altered
and would be an
indication for brain
imaging a patient
presenting with
signs of increased
intracranial pressure
some of these are listed
below evaluation of
known brain lesions
tumor, aneurysm,
a known neurologic
disease,
very commonly
multiple sclerosis.
The four modalities
we're going
to discuss today
are CAT scan,
MRI,
carotid ultrasound,
and conventional
angiogram. CAT scan, MRI,
and carotid ultrasound
are three forms
of cross-sectional
imaging and conventional
angiogram is in
its own category.
For your information,
there are other
modalities that can
be used to image
the brain. However,
these are the ones
we're going to discuss
today. The first
modality we're going to
discuss is CAT scan
or CT scan. This is a
picture in the middle
of a CAT scan machine.
There's a bed
component and then what
I call a donut
component. The bed goes
into the donut as
the CT is performed.
This donut contains
x-ray beams that
are oriented around
the donut, and across
from each x-ray
beam is a receptor.
The receptor receives
the x-ray beam
after it has
coursed through the
patient, and the
resultant image is
what we as
radiologists interpret.
On the bottom right
hand corner I just
have an image of three
cat skin, sorry one
cat skin of a
patient's head in three
planes which are the
typical projections
that are reconstructions
that we perform
in radiology to
ultimately interpret
the image. So the
first image here is a
sagittal image through
the head and neck.
The middle one is
a coronal image
and the third one
is an axial image.
So this is a more
detailed schematic here
demonstrating the
patient lying on the
CAT scan table,
the source of x-ray
beam that's within
the CAT scan, and the
detector on the other
side of the patient
with the resultant
image on the right.
This image on the
right here shows
how different tissues
in the body appear
differently based
on how they have
each attenuated the
radiation beams.
This slide is to
introduce you to the
concept of windows and
CAT scan. these windows
are a software-based
view of different
types of tissue so
we use one window to
analyze bone we use
another window to
analyze soft tissue
and so on and so forth
I'm going to show you
in more detail in the
slides to come this
is an example of the
difference in appearance
between the bone
and brain windows
in a CAT scan of the
head as you see in
the image on the left
it looks very different
than the image on
the right. The bone
is in great detail.
Now this, these two
images are from the
same patient at the
same slice of the head.
It's at the level of
the temporal bones,
the orbits, and the
cerebellum. So you see
here on the image
on the left, you can
clearly make out the bone
cortex, the medullary
cavity. We're at
the level of the
temporal bone, so you
can see the little air
cells that are within
the temporal bones.
In the image
on the right,
you lose all of this
fine bony detail. But
what we do get,
because it's the brain
window, is we get fine
detail of the brain.
As you can see in the
image on the left,
the bone window
shows nothing of the
brain. And the image
on the right, the
brain window shows
essentially nothing
of the bone. And this
is how we analyze
the different CT
images in radiology.
One more example
for you, showing you
two different windows,
the lung window and
the soft tissue window
in a CAT scan of
the chest. So these
are two coronal
images at the same
slice through the heart,
through the lungs
of a patient. The
image on the left is
the lung window. So
those two black fields
that surround the
heart are the lungs
and you can see the
pulmonary arteries
within the lungs and
although this
patient doesn't have
any lung disease
we would be able to
find lung disease on
the image on the left.
The image on the right
on the other hand
focuses on the soft
tissues. As you can see
the lungs lose their
detail and what we
get detail of is the
soft tissue. So we see
the shoulders, we can
see the muscles and
the fat around the
shoulder and the axillary
regions. We see the
organs of the upper
abdomen, the liver,
the stomach, the
mesenteric fat. We see
the mediastinum. We see
the aorta, the pulmonary
artery, the heart
with its atrium and
ventricle. So all of
these details are much
more apparent on the
soft tissue window
than the lung window.
What are the
advantages of CT?
Excellent for
evaluation of
acute hemorrhage.
Excellent for
evaluation of
bone and calcium.
Why would we need to
look at bone and calcium?
Some examples are
evaluation of calcifications
in the setting of
tumor, and evaluation
of acute fracture in
the setting of trauma.
CT also provides great
anatomic detail of
multiple tissue types
all in one study.
Some of the other
benefits of CAT scan are
that it is fast. We
can essentially perform
a CAT scan of one
body part in less than
30 seconds. it is
non-invasive, and it
is cost-effective when
compared to MRI. When
compared to ultrasound,
on the other
hand, which is another
modality we're going
to discuss, it is not
cost-effective. So
in order of most expensive
to least expensive,
the four modalities
we're going to
discuss today, the most
expensive is conventional
angiogram, the next
one down is MRI,
the next one
down is CAT scan
and the cheapest
is ultrasound.
So why do we
order a CAT scan
when we want to
image the brain?
Most commonly, it
is used in emergency
scenarios. As I
said, it's great for
hemorrhage and fracture.
So of course, we're
going to use it in
the setting of trauma.
It's fast. So that
makes it really good
for evaluation of ******
because in ******,
time is brain and
we want to act fast.
Syncope, altered
mental status, all of
these presenting
scenarios can lead
to imaging of the
head with CAT scan.
Another reason
we do CAT scan
is to characterize
tumors.
And then there's a
subset of CAT scan
called CT angiography,
which is a specific
study to look at the
vessels of the head
and neck and in those
cases we're looking
for arterial rupture
maybe in stenosis
or high blood pressure
sorry maybe in the
setting of trauma or
high blood pressure
arterial stenosis
aneurysm and
dissection as you see
from the prior slide
there are many or
two slides ago,
actually. There
are many advantages
to CT and many
indications for CT.
However, there's one main
disadvantage, and
this slide is the
most important
one for your exam,
and that is radiation.
Now, I have to preface
this conversation to
say that our knowledge
of the harmful effects
of radiation in medical
imaging are limited.
We are still collecting
data to get more
conclusive answers about
the harmful effects.
Our current knowledge
is based on high
-dose acute exposures
after the atomic bomb.
But what effects
do low doses
over a long period
of time cause?
We're still finding
out. Now, we are
exposed to radiation
in normal life.
We obtain about 3
millisieverts per
year just living
on planet Earth.
Millisieverts are a
unit used to measure
a dose of radiation
to the human body.
Now, frequent flying
is something that
can increase your
dose of radiation.
Having lots of
CAT scans, working
in a radiology
department,
there are many
things that can
increase your dose
of radiation above
the normal level
in life. But having
CAT scans, which
contain radiation,
as do some other
forms of imaging and
radiology, there is a
long-term lifetime risk
of developing cancer
from the radiation.
although this number
is not exact the
estimates are that the
lifetime risk of both
fatal and non-fatal
cancer from a ct scan is
about one in two
thousand and that risk
increases for if you
look at just non-fatal
cancers it's about
one in a thousand will
have a non-fatal
cancer from a cat scan,
from the radiation
incurred from a CAT scan.
So that's the main
take-home point.
I want to highlight
this point
because although
CAT scan is very,
very important in
medical imaging,
it is important to know
its main disadvantage
and to try to work
around it. We have a
theme that we use in
radiology, which is
Alara. And that is the
intention to radiate
as low as reasonably
possible for patients.
So some of the things
that we can do to
monitor and manage the
radiation dose is that
when possible, there
are low dose protocols
that we can perform.
It's not always
possible, but it can
be done. There are
protective aprons that
we can have patients wear
on the body parts that
are not being imaged
to protect them from
excess radiation.
And then we have to
specifically assess
the risks and benefits
for performing
CAT scans in pregnant
women and children.
So even though we
are all at risk of
cancer from the
radiation in CAT scan,
pregnant women and
children, because of
their rapidly proliferating
and new cells,
are at greater risk.
And so we take even
greater precaution with
them. So this lifetime
risk of both fatal
and non-fatal cancer
is the main take-home
point for the exam.
A little bit of
information on contrast
in CAT scan. As a
radiologist, I get a
lot of phone calls
from clinicians about
questions. Should we
give contrast? What
kind of contrast
should we give? This is
what I'm looking for.
So this is a little
introduction for you
as future clinicians
to understand the
role of contrast.
CT contrast is an
iodinated solution
that can be used to
highlight certain
disease entities
in certain organs.
We can administer
it in three ways,
intravenously,
******, and rectally.
Oral and ******
forms are for
evaluation of
the GI tract.
Intravenous form is
for evaluation of
organs and vessels.
The way that organs
take up contrast
is a process called
enhancement and in
radiology we've described
patterns of enhancement
and we've associated
them with certain
disease processes.
So I'm just going
to give you a few
examples because even
as medical students
you are expected to
know certain really
common diseases and
how they present in
terms of radiologic
contrast enhancement.
This is an example of
an axial CT image of
a brain at the same
level on the left
before contrast and on
the right after contrast.
This is an example of
diffuse enhancement
of a mass located
in the left frontal
lobe. The diagnosis
is meningioma. Now,
there are other lesions
that can show diffuse
enhancement in the
brain, but this is
an example of number
one, how the pattern
of enhancement can
help us guide us to a
diagnosis because there's
only a few entities
that show this pattern
of enhancement.
And secondly, this
is to show you how
important contrast
is when we're
looking for certain
things like a tumor.
As you see on the
image on the left, we
can see that there's
something not right,
but we can't really
characterize it. The
image on the right
clearly shows the lesion.
It shows the pattern
of enhancement, and
it gives us so much
more information than
the image on the
left did. And so this
is why contrast is
important in radiology.
This is another axial
CT image through
the brain, pre- and
post-contrast, giving
an example of ring
enhancement or
peripheral enhancement.
As you see, the contrast
has been taken up
only in the periphery.
So only the ring
of the surrounding,
the peripheral
structure is enhancing
and the center is
not enhancing. The
classic disease entity
associated with ring
enhancement in the
brain is an abscess.
And this is
important for you to
know, not for my
exam, but in general.
The other main
disease entity that
causes ring enhancement
in the brain
is glioblastoma
multiforme, which is
an aggressive form
of brain cancer.
If I'm going to
discuss to you CT
contrast, I have to
have a slide about
the risks of IV
contrast. contrast.
There are actually
two slides. The first
risk is allergic
reaction. So every patient
who is sent for a CAT
scan with contrast
fills out a questionnaire.
And this questionnaire
asks them about
their history of
allergy. Do they have
allergies to anything?
And have they had a
previous allergy to ct
contrast the allergies
can range from mild
to severe they can
be treated it's very
important to know
about the possibility
of these because we
can we can manage them
we can a patient who
has a concern for
allergy but really needs
contrast can be pre
-treated with certain
medications as described
here. Also, if we
do get to a point of
an anaphylactic
response, we can treat
the patient and there's
always a crash cart
next to the CAT scan
machine. The second
risk of IV contrast
in CT is nephropathy.
This is very important
because you can
put someone into
acute renal failure
from one dose of IV
CT contrast if we
haven't done the
proper pre-screening.
So part of the pre
-screening for CT IV
contrast is a serum
creatinine level.
Any creatinine above
1.5, we usually
do not give
contrast. There are
scenarios in which
we may bypass our
hospital protocols.
For example,
life-threatening trauma,
you know, life
-threatening pulmonary
embolism. If we're
concerned that the
benefits of the CAT
scan and the contrast
outweigh the risk of
acute renal failure,
we may give contrast
anyway. And that's
a conversation
between the doctor
ordering the study and
the radiologist who's
covering the department
at that time.
Aside from a high
creatinine level,
diabetic patients,
even with a normal
creatinine are at
risk for renal failure
from IV contrast
because diabetes
is a disease that
affects the kidneys.
So we like to know if
a patient is diabetic
and we may choose to take
some extra precaution
with them. Maybe
they might get a dose
of hydration before
the contrast is given.
Specifically,
diabetics on metformin.
These patients, the
drug metformin must
be discontinued
for 48 hours before
contrast because
there is a reaction.
Patients who have
chronic renal failure
can get CT contrast
as long as their
hemodialysis is
scheduled within 24 hours
of the contrast
being administered.
So when do we order a
CAT scan with contrast?
Typically not in
trauma scenarios.
It's typically a different
scenario like when
we suspect a tumor or
when we're evaluating
a known tumor, when
there's some kind of
vascular disorder, a
******, an aneurysm.
Now this may confuse you
because the first line
imaging that's
indicated when a patient
presents with a ******
is a non-contrast CT.
But if the non-contrast
CT shows that there
is no hemorrhage, we
then follow that up
with a contrast CT to
look at the arteries
and see if there's
an area of stenosis
or an occlusion in a
vessel to the brain.
So when we're looking for
infection or abscess,
that's another
indication for
CTIV contrast.
Just to reiterate,
if we are looking for
acute hemorrhage,
which is essentially
all trauma scenarios,
and often in a
scenario of altered
mental status, often
in a scenario of
******, we do a non
-contrast CT first
as a first line and
then we can do a
contrast study to look
for other entities.
It's very important
in brain imaging
especially in the
emergency setting
to rule out acute
hemorrhage as a
first line order.
The second modality
we're going to discuss
is magnetic resonance
imaging or MRI.
It looks very similar
to the CAT scan
machine. There's a
patient bed which moves
in and out of another
donut, this donut is
a little bit bigger
than the CAT scan
donut. And inside
this donut, instead of
helical x-ray beams,
there's a big magnet.
This magnet
has pulsations.
The pulsations
that are performed
during the MRI sequence
excite the atoms
within the body.
the atoms within
the body then
relax after
being excited.
The relaxation times
of those atoms is what
creates the different
images on an MRI.
So as you can see
in the image on
the bottom right
hand corner here,
different types of
tissue have different
relaxation times and
show up differently
on an image and
it's through this
differential appearance
that we interpret MRI.
Just want to discuss MRI
with you a little bit.
The sequences in
MRI are similar to
the windows in CT.
So we use different
sequences in MRI to
look at different
types of tissue
and I just want
that to be the take
-home point here.
So what are the
advantages of MRI?
Superb visualization
of soft tissues,
brain, spinal
cord, nerves,
ligaments,
tendons, tumors.
You probably hear
about people getting
MRIs of joints a
lot. I got an MRI of
the shoulder, I got
an MRI of the knee.
I got an MRI of
the wrist. That's
because MRI is excellent
for soft tissue.
Another benefit of
MRI, no radiation.
That's a huge benefit.
You can probably
guess we really
like to do MRI on
pregnant women and
children over CAT scan.
There's a third
advantage of MRI, which
is that we can actually
do an angiogram.
It's called an MR
angiogram with an
MRI without
contrast. There is a
technology, an MRI,
that allows us to not
give any contrast,
yet we can actually
evaluate the vessels,
look for stenosis,
look for aneurysms
arteriovenous malformations
everything so this
is a these are
three great advantages
of MRI so based
on our understanding
now of MRI when do
we order an MRI we
may order an MRI in
cases of early ******
if the patient's
symptoms have begun
less than 12 hours ago
and a CAT scan has
been done and it is
completely negative,
doesn't show any
abnormality, we may then
follow that CT up with
an MRI and the MRI
might show a ******,
an acute ******, when
a CT did not show
it. And that's a big
advantage of MRI over
CT. So it is still
the typical protocol
for patients to have
a ct without contrast
as a first line study
remember ct takes
less than 30 seconds
when a patient arrives
to the er with a
facial droop aphasia
a dead leg non-responsive
you want to know
you want to get an
image immediately so
it is not likely that
you're going to send
the patient for a 30
-minute MRI, right?
Even though MRI is
very beneficial,
we always usually
throw them into the CAT
scan machine, 30
seconds come out, at
least we have some idea
of what's going on.
But if a CT were
negative and you highly
suspect, oh, look,
there's a face droop,
so clearly something's
wrong, but the CT was
negative, then we
would do an MRI. MRI.
Another indication
for assessment of
MRI is characterization
of tumors.
Also, we can assess
the cranial nerves.
We can't really
evaluate cranial
nerves with CT, but
we can with MRI.
And then as I mentioned,
there's something,
a subset of MRI
called the MR
angiography, which is
specifically evaluation
of the vessels of
the head and neck.
As I've alluded to
a bit, there are
disadvantages to
MRI. It is expensive.
The machine, the
expertise required to
maintain the machine,
even the room
itself has special,
has specifications.
So in general, running
an MRI is expensive.
the donut of the MRI
machine is a little
bit smaller than the
one of the CAT scan
machine and patients
need to spend more
time in there so
patients are more prone
to claustrophobia
with MRI than with CAT
scan so sometimes
claustrophobia prevents
a patient from being
able to have an
MRI it is also slow
sometimes time is not
in our favor and we
can't afford an MRI
Metallic implants are a
major disadvantage
to MRI.
If a patient has a
metallic implant, they
need to be pre-screened
for the type to make
sure that it is
compatible with MRI.
Because if it is not
compatible, the patient
is at risk of the
large magnet moving the
implanted device and
causing physical harm.
so the devices can
either heat up from
the magnetic
excitation or they can
actually migrate and
this is a this is
a major issue and
we need to take
precaution as you
can see in this image
this office chair
had a magnetic
component and it should
not be in the mri
room but it was in
the mri room and
because this magnet
is so strong it
flew through the air
into the machine.
So it's very important
to be aware of
magnet issues in relation
to MRI. The weight
limit on an MRI
machine is less than a
CAT scan machine. I
believe most CAT scan
machines can take
up to 400 something.
MRI only 350. So that's
a limitation. And
then of course, there
are some risks of IV
contrast, which we're
now going to get into.
So MRI IV contrast
is not the
same substance
as CTIV contrast.
MRI IV contrast is a
gadolinium
-based solution,
gadolinium, the
heavy metal.
When do we order an
MRI with contrast
as opposed to
without? The same
reasons that we give
contrast in CT are
those that we give
contrast in MRI.
If we would like to
evaluate a brain tumor,
if we're looking for
vascular pathology,
or if there is
suspicion of infection.
These are four images
through the same
patient. The two on the
top are axial, pre- and
post-contrast. The
two on the bottom are
coronal, pre- and post
-contrast, showing you
how contrast can
highlight a small tumor
and how it's possible
that without contrast,
this tumor could be
completely missed and
why it is important
to give contrast if
you're looking for a
tumor. As you see, the
tumor is circled in
yellow on the two post
-contrast images,
axial and coronal, and
it's quite hard to see,
only kind of shows up
in retrospect on the
pre-contrast images.
This is another
example of how IV
contrast just lights
up disease entities.
The image on the far
left is a pre-contrast
axial MRI through
the level of the
ventricles. the middle
and far right images
are axial and coronal
post-contrast images
of the same patient
showing abnormal
leptomeningeal enhancements
in a patient with
neurosarcoidosis now
this is a this is a
study where i can with
confidence say many
people would miss the
disease if contrast
had not been administered.
It is very hard
to see this
abnormality on the pre
-contrast image, but on
the post-contrast image,
you just can't miss
it, and this is
why contrast is important,
and it's important
to look critically
at your patient,
develop a differential
diagnosis, and work
up based on that
differential diagnosis.
Risks of IV-MRI contrast.
Ironically, CT
and MRI contrast,
despite being
different solutions,
they both have
harmful effects on the
kidneys. They are
completely different disease
processes. In IV MRI
contrast, there is
a very, very rare
but serious condition
called nephrogenic
systemic fibrosis, which
occurs after IV
contrast and really only
in patients who have
renal impairment.
So for that reason,
we also pre-screen
patients who are
going to get MRI
IV contrast for
their renal function.
If we're ordering
a CAT scan and
we want to pre
-screen for kidney
function, we get a
serum creatinine.
If we are pre
-screening a patient for
MRI IV contrast,
we get a GFR. GFR.
If the GFR is less
than 30, those
patients cannot get
IV MRI contrast.
There's also a lesser
known entity called
gadolinium deposition
disease. There's
not too much known
about it today.
However, we have seen
in autopsies that
patients who have
received IV MRI contrast
in their life have
deposits of the
heavy metal in their
brain. We are still
trying to understand
if there are harmful
effects associated
with that. So it's
something to be aware
of. And then there's
also allergic reaction
associated with
MRI contrast. It's
not as common as CT
contrast, but something
to be aware of.
We have reached the
third modality that
we're going to
discuss today in terms
of modalities used
in neuroimaging.
So carotid duplex
ultrasound is a form
of cross-sectional
imaging of only the
cervical segments
of the major vessels
to the head. So
while I've described,
this lecture is called
clinical applications
of neuroimaging.
Neuroimaging really
encompasses the brain
and spine. But for
the purposes of
this lecture, we're
mainly talking about
head and neck imaging.
And carotid duplex
ultrasound is for
evaluation of the
common carotid arteries,
the internal carotid
artery, cervical
segments only, the
external carotid
artery, and the vertebral
arteries, cervical
segments only. We
can also look at
veins with carotid
duplex ultrasound.
The word duplex in
carotid ultrasound
refers to the two
components of information
that we receive
from this study.
Remember, this is
an ultrasound of the
carotid vessels. When
we do the ultrasound,
as shown in this
photograph here,
a transducer is
placed on the tissue
of interest, in
this case, the
cervical vessels,
to send and
receive sound waves
from the tissue.
The software then creates
grayscale and color
Doppler images, as
shown here on the bottom
right-hand corner,
grayscale in A, color
Doppler in B, to show
us both the tissue and
then the flow of blood
within the tissue.
The next step
of the duplex
component is on
the next slide.
The second component
of the duplex
ultrasound is spectral
analysis. So as the
blood flow is measured
by the ultrasound,
the software provides
a waveform and we
know what normal
vascular waveforms are
supposed to be for
arteries and for veins.
And we can therefore
identify stenosis,
occlusion, abnormal
rhythms, all using
spectral analysis and
carotid ultrasound.
Advantages of carotid
ultrasound, non-invasive,
the most cost
-effective neuroimaging
modality. It can even
be performed portably.
While most of the
studies in radiology,
the patient has
to come to the
radiology department
to have the exam. In
this case, we can
take the exam to the
patient, ICU, emergency
room, anywhere
they are. It's also
quite reliable.
So what situations
would cause
us as clinicians
to order a carotid
ultrasound for
our patients?
When we suspect
or would like
to follow up on
a known carotid
or vertebral
artery stenosis.
So just like in
the first slide,
altered mental status,
transient ischemic
attack, syncope
and ****** are all
presentations that may
be resultant from a
carotid or vertebral
artery stenosis and
a carotid ultrasound
would be indicated.
Now, the order in which
we would perform any
of those four modalities
that I discussed
today is a little bit
more complicated, but
the main point of this
lecture is for you
to know that carotid
ultrasound is on your
list of options of things
to order when you're
trying to work up a
certain presentation.
Now, the last indication
or presentation,
actually it's neither,
it's a finding on
physical exam, which
is a brewy, would be
another reason to
order a carotid duplex
ultrasound. And that's
because a brewy,
which is defined as a
palpable thrill over
the carotid artery,
is a physical finding
that has been
associated with carotid
stenosis. So when you
palpate a brewy, you
should be concerned
that a patient has
carotid stenosis. And
one of the ways you can
work that up is via
carotid ultrasound.
Disadvantages of
The disadvantages
are technical
factors. Although
this is a reliable
study, this is
technician dependent.
Human beings perform
the ultrasound,
not a machine.
So every one
comes out a little
bit differently.
image degradation can
occur in ultrasound
due to factors like
a large patient
ultrasound waves move
differently through
different types of
tissue if there's a large
amount of fat before
superficial to an
organ of interest that
can get in the way of
getting good images
also a patient may
not be able to position
themselves in in the
optimal way for the
study to be done and
that can get in the
way of good images.
Patients might be in
pain and not be able
to tolerate the study.
There is a degree of
compression that the
ultrasound requires.
Now certain
physical parameters
like IV lines, a
ventilator, a bandage,
they may get
in the way of a
region of interest
being evaluated.
Conventional
angiogram is the last
modality we will
discuss today.
It is a fluoroscopy
-guided form of imaging
that is done by
accessing a vessel
of interest via
a peripheral
artery or vein
catheterization and
administering
intravenous contrast.
so the first thing you
need to know is that
this is a surgical
procedure it is done
in the operating room
so the fluoroscopy
table that you see on
the right here is put
in an operating room
the doctors are prepped
as surgeons and the
patient is prepped
you know as if for an
operation the site is
sterile and there are
two screens here or
multiple screens
provided with the table
so what happens is we
access a peripheral
artery or vein a
catheter is introduced
we administer contrast
to guide us centrally
into the body to a
vessel of interest
could be an artery
could be a vein and then
we administer contrast
within that artery
and vein and then
we can look at it in
great detail and we
can also treat it in
the same procedure.
So let's get into it.
This is a schematic
to show you access
arterial or venous
access usually
from the groin the
common femoral or
superficial femoral
artery or vein,
alternatively may be
done from the arm.
The picture on the right
is a fluoroscopically
obtained angiogram
of the aorta.
So you see contrast
in the aorta
filling the two
left and right
renal arteries.
You even see some
enhancement of the
actual kidneys.
And then below that,
you see the iliac
bifurcation. Between
the renal arteries and
the iliac bifurcation
is an abnormal
dilation of the aorta,
which is an aneurysm.
So even though this
isn't neuroimaging,
this is just to
show you, get you
comfortable with
the concept of a
conventional angiogram,
how it's performed.
The main advantage
of a conventional
angiogram is the
opportunity to diagnose and
treat in the same study.
So the image on the
right here shows you
a cerebral angiogram,
a conventional angiogram
of the head, in
which we have diagnosed,
the image in A,
an MCA occlusion,
and the image in B we
have treated that
occlusion and we have
reperfusion. So let
me back up a bit.
This patient
went to the OR,
got prepped, the doctors
prepped, they
went into the OR,
they performed the
catheterization from a
peripheral site, maybe
the wrist, maybe the
neck. They accessed
the internal carotid
artery, which is the
short rooted arrow in A.
The internal carotid
artery showed patency.
The arrowhead
shows patency of
the anterior
cerebral artery.
And then the long
-based arrow shows
an abrupt cutoff of
the middle cerebral
artery, which would
cause a ******.
The patient was then
given a clot, something
to dissolve the
clot, a medication
inside the vessel to
break up the clot. It
worked. The vessel
became patent, and now
we can actually see
on the angiogram the
branches of the
middle cerebral artery
perfusing where they
previously were not. So
this is a classic
example of the use of
a conventional angiogram
in neuroimaging.
Indications for
conventional angiogram.
When we have vascular
disease that we
intend to treat in
artery or in vein,
so a congenital
malformation, as shown in the
bottom right hand
corner image here. this
is a cerebral venogram
showing an abnormal
arteriovenous malformation
in the brain the
image above that is a
normal cerebral venogram
i think you can
appreciate that a few more
vessels are filling
with contrast in the
image on the bottom
than on the image on the
top those vessels that
are abnormally filling
with contrast on a
venogram are an abnormal
communication between
arteries and veins.
They're accessory
abnormal vessels that have
been formed in the womb
and they can lead to
seizure. They can lead
to hemorrhage in the
brain. They can lead
to ****** and they can
lean to death. So these
patients are often
treated at a very young
age with coiling and
essentially closing
some of these
abnormal arteriovenous
channels. So this
is a situation in
which it cannot be
treated from outside
the body. It needs
to be treated
in vessel and a
conventional angiogram
would be necessary.
A second indication
would be vascular
disease presenting
as atherosclerotic
stenosis. This is
probably the most common
reason for cerebral
angiogram. A patient
presents with an
acute ******, they
have a known occlusion,
and you want to
treat inside the vessel.
There are certain
patients who are
candidates for this.
These would get a
conventional angiogram.
Sometimes there's a
vascular stenosis or
abnormality caused by
external compression,
like maybe from a
tumor or something.
That might be an
indication to perform a
cerebral angiogram.
And then angioplasty.
Another treatment of
stenosis is balloon
placement within
a vessel. So you
can actually administer
medication within
an artery to break
up a clot, and
you can also inflate
a balloon within
the artery to open
an area of stenosis.
So angioplasty is
another indication for
conventional angiogram.
Sometimes patients
in trauma need a
conventional angiogram.
If there is vascular
injury, it can
sometimes be treated
with an angiogram.
Also, aneurysms
and arterial venous
malformations that are
not congenital also
can be treated with
cerebral angiogram.
Disadvantages of
conventional angiogram.
The main one is
its invasiveness.
This is a huge
operation to take on. It
requires an OR. It requires
sedation. It requires
IV contrast, which comes
with its own risks.
It often requires a
hospital stay. And
then there are a whole
host of complications.
There can be injury
to vessels. You can
actually cause a
dissection or a bleed or
an infection when
performing an angiogram
without even attempting
the treatment. So
this is a risky procedure
and patients need
to be chosen wisely
for this procedure.
The other disadvantage
of conventional
angiogram is that it's
limited in what we see
during this study as
from the images i showed
you we really only see
vessels we don't see
how those vessels
relate to the structures
around them so this
is why a conventional
angiogram is mainly
used when we know of a
disease entity and we
intend to treat because
going in and doing a
conventional angiogram
blindly without knowing
what's going on in
the surrounding organs
is an outdated entity.
Nowadays, with the
proliferation of cross
-sectional imaging that
we have, ultrasound,
CAT scan, MRI, we
almost never perform a
conventional angiogram
without having first
done some type of cross
-sectional imaging.
In summary, we
have discussed four
main modalities used
in neuroimaging.
Regarding CAT scan
and MRI, we've
discussed some
issues pertaining to
the IV contrast
with those studies.
CAT scan of the
brain is best
for acute trauma,
diagnosing
hemorrhage, and
acute fracture.
MRI brain is best
for evaluation of
the soft tissues like
nerves and ligaments
and when trying
to avoid radiation
in cases of pregnancy
and children.
CT and MRI with contrast
is performed when
we want to evaluate
vascular disease and
to assess for patterns
of enhancement in
other lesions such as
infection and tumor.
Carotid duplex study
only evaluates the
cervical vessels and
conventional angiogram
is best when we
have a vascular
pathology and we want
to both look at that
pathology and treat
it in the same study.
That's when we do
conventional angiogram.
I hope this has been
a helpful introduction
to both radiology
and neuroimaging.
I'm happy to receive
any questions you
have. The best email
for me is my name,
Sherry, S-H-E-R-R-Y
dot Zachary, Z-A-K
-H-A-R-Y at gmail
.com. I look forward
to hearing from you.
Have a great day.